sterling K Brown posted this beautiful
shot of his this is us family back
together again the new season starts
next month on NBC but in the meantime
sterling has been flexing his vocal
muscles as Michael yo found out welcome
to my piggy gadget lab my wife and
children will tell you from time to time
daddy is just strange because he starts
speaking in foreign accents all the time
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for sterling
says Gary the pig was created to look
like him but he recently had eye surgery
so no more of those signature glasses I
just got LASIK surgery so otherwise I
would be rockin friends like that
okay the goatee normally is mike is my
go-to right now I don't have it whoa
cherlene joins jason sudeikis and Bill
Hader who are back and joining forces to
protect their Islands from a new villain
voiced by SNL's Leslie Jones
the sequel also features some celebrity
kids Nicole and Keith's girls faith and
Sunday gal gadot seven-year-old Alma and
viola Davis's daughter Genesis yeah
what's the number-one thing that makes
you angry I get a little aggro in
traffic you know living in Los Angeles
there's just a lot of cars people that
don't have manners okay good don't worry
to my friends what's your significant
others what is the look you give them
when you're angry my look yeah probably
gritting my teeth behind it like it's
like a classic angry face when
psychologists try to decide it for a
psychopath how do I feel Oh red flag
that fella what's your angry look you
give pay you ready
look the smile it was you know I got to
do what's my yeah no we're not gonna
fight if I have to go out to the car and
just sit down and play a little Angry
Birds by myself you see how I did then I
will now Angry Birds isn't the only big
animated movie for Sterling it seems
he's also lending his voice to frozen
- even though sterling will still not
confirm or deny it
[Music]
[Applause]